mike winkelmann also known as beeple has
been creating a new piece of art
every day for over 13 years now he's
been making art since before
netflix had a streaming service before
toy story had a third installment
and before bitcoin even existed with his
massive
69 million dollar sale at christie's
he's now the third
most expensive living artist in the
world
people's life is an incredible story of
grit and determination
so stick with me while i take you
through it i'm john coogan
and this is the saga of mike winkelmann
aka people
people grew up in a small wisconsin town
that's home to just over 5 000 people
he didn't initially plan to be an artist
though so he went to purdue university
and studied computer science after
graduating he spent some time designing
websites for small companies
but would immerse himself in creative
projects during his off hours
in 2007 he started every days with the
goal of creating a new piece of art
every single day
on may 1st 2007 he published his first
work
a simple drawing of a man with a
mustache titled uber jay
repetition is a great way to build a new
skill slowly over time
instead of trying to binge learn
everything there is to know about
something new
and potentially burning out doing a
little bit every day
can add up slowly and help build mastery
while beeple is certainly responsible
for popularizing the idea of everydays
he actually got the idea from another
artist named tom judd
who had done a new drawing every day for
a full year
in the early years of the project beeple
bounced around between mediums
he started with just a pen and paper
moved on to cinema 4d and 3d rendering
for a while
and then spent a year on photography
before moving back into the 3d world
learning the ins and outs of a physical
camera is incredibly valuable when
you're working in 3d programs like
cinema 4d
this is because each 3d scene is
rendered using a simulated camera
and all the real world settings like
focal length aperture and shutter speed
translate essentially one to one into
the 3d world
but beeple is really known for his
cinema 4d work where he pioneered a
cyberpunky sci-fi
look that has influenced tons of other
designers who use the software
in the late 2010s people became so
popular in the cinema 4d community that
there was significant pushback against
the everyday trend that had grown out of
his initial project
essentially up and coming motion
designers felt like they had to post new
artwork
every single day in order to be taken
seriously and get work
even though the everyday process was
incredibly rewarding for people
it simply wouldn't work for everyone
just listen to how he describes his
process to nick campbell from grayscale
gorilla
something i learned is that you actually
do these every day
now i i probably like a lot of you are
like well he probably batches a few of
them
does like four on a monday and then
posts them through the week
but you actually do it every day what
why is that an important part of the
process
well it's an every day so it kind of
i would cheat so fast yeah but that's
the thing
i mean that the whole point of it is is
to get better incrementally and not try
and like i'm gonna [ __ ] cram all
night and stay up and like
it's it's about the like just kind of
spacing out the work and
being able to see that progress that
kind of obsessive work ethic clearly
paid off here
but it's certainly not the only way to
create something amazing
after all margaret mitchell spent 10
years writing dawn with the wind
which won a pulitzer prize and was
adapted into an academy award-winning
film
similarly jrl tolkien spent over a
decade writing the lord of the rings
mostly due to the fact that he still had
a full-time academic position
while he was writing the books so great
things can clearly be accomplished
regardless of whether you choose to
publish
incrementally like people or spend a
decade honing a masterpiece before
releasing it like tolkien
but publishing iteratively does have one
distinct advantage
publicity people's everyday project
gained steam very slowly at first
but it started paying off long before
any of the work was sold at auction
in 2010 he was able to collaborate with
flying lotus and
in the spirit of community collaboration
people open sourced the cinema 4d files
and allowed other 3d animators to learn
from his work
and use the 3d models in new works
people's flying lotus project was very
well received
and led to more client work with artists
like ariana grande
justin bieber childish gambino and nicki
minaj
as beeples following grew and his visual
style became more distinct
he eventually got offers to work on even
bigger projects
in 2018 louis vuitton reached out to use
some of his everydays
in their next ready-to-wear collection
the images appeared on 13 of 45 pieces
in the collection
and helped people reach a new echelon of
legitimacy but within the design
community
a controversy was stirring about whether
or not beeple had been compensated
fairly for his work
chris doe the ceo and founder of the
future
interviewed beeple and dug into the
louis vuitton deal let's take it back to
louis vuitton
okay you were a little bit drunk oh yeah
there was some alcohol involved how dare
you
it was your party so i understand you
you were talking to me it's like hey man
did you hear about the lv project i'm
like what lv project you're like man
they bought these images for me
and what do you think i would what do
you think it's a fair price to charge
and then
you showed me how much work he had done
for this thing i'm like oh it should be
this amount
and you're like oh my god no it was this
amount that's where i disagree with you
of course they have more money that they
could have paid me but
in my view and that's where i think
sometimes designers have a tendency to
overestimate their importance to a
project
in this case with louis vuitton they
didn't need me they
absolutely did not [ __ ] need me they
might have wanted me
that's very different there's a
difference for how much you'll pay for
something you want and something unique
this exchange is fascinating to me
because it reveals that
even though beeple has been honing his
craft for over a decade
he still has imposter syndrome and
doesn't understand the true value of his
art
and that's why nft auctions are such an
interesting solution to this problem
nft stands for non-fungible token
essentially a digital signature backed
by blockchain technology
that proves ownership of something
unlike bitcoin
which are all identical by design nfts
are unique
to some degree what nfts offer for sale
is the idea of scarcity
and that's perfect for people since he
releases all of his artwork for free on
instagram
and any image can be downloaded and
copied endlessly
there hasn't been a good way for him to
treat his work as fine art and sell it
as other artists would
the last six months have been incredible
for people in november of 2020
he sold an nft of his video crossroads
for
six hundred and sixty six dollars and
his reaction was pretty priceless
i was like oh my god i sold a piece
for sixty six thousand it was just like
insane in december of twenty twenty
people sold three point five million
dollars worth of art in one day
which was quickly followed by crossroads
reselling on the nft secondary market
for 6.6 million dollars of which people
got 10
then in march christie's a centuries-old
auction house
sold a 5 000 image montage by people for
nearly 70 million dollars
that makes people the third most
expensive living artist in the world
but not everyone in the art community is
happy about people's rise and newfound
legitimacy
the new york magazine art critic jerry
saltz called beeple's work
just really really derivative sci-fi and
conan and star wars crapola as far as
imagery and imagination go
whatever the medium they're just bad
kitsch even though i love beeple
i can see where salt is coming from here
beeple focuses on popular topics and has
never identified as the type of
high-minded artist
that might be embraced by the mainstream
art world and no one has been more
disparaging of people's work
than people himself just listen to how
he describes himself in this interview
well it says on your website that you
suck ass at what you do
i don't know when you wrote that but
you've been doing work many years ago
they told but it was many years ago yeah
do you still think
you suck ass i think there's a lot of
areas that i need to
work on um there's just a lot of things
that i
really know nothing about and just
squeak
my way through just hacking crap
together
but at the end of the day what's
incredible about beeple is his
dedication
he's been making a new piece of art
every day for 13 years straight
and ultimately that's what i think these
art collectors are buying
there's a reason why the collage of his
first 5 000 pieces
sold for so much more than any one
artwork
it represents the progress and focus
that beeple has brought to his work for
years and years
in some ways every day's the first five
thousand days
is more performance art than digital art
anyone could compile five thousand
images into a collage
but only people could create this
specific collage and what it represents
people's work is the ultimate refutation
of the my kid could make that argument
that people often levy when art sells
for exorbitant prices
sure your kid probably could learn
cinema 4d and start pumping out renders
but by the time they had 5000 every day
is published they
probably wouldn't even be a kid anymore
and that's gotta be worth something